One of the things we do know is that,
you know,
as you stretch out the inequality you
make men particularly on the lower end of
the distribution,
more and more likely to be aggressive.
It's sort of like imagine every
man has a threshold for violence.
Um,
and status is important,
demand knocked that it's
not important to women,
but it's different.
It's a different kind of status.
It status is important to men because
it's one of the things that makes them
marketable as partners to women.
So it actually turns out to
be quite important to Mandan.
Men tend to compete with
one another for status,
hierarchy position and in
a really unequal society.
If you're like a low rung guy then and
you don't have any opportunity to rise
because the society isn't
structured so that there's mobility,
then the more aggressive guys tend to
turn into criminality and you know,
and so you could say there's a threshold
for criminality and the more inequality
pressure you put on a particular area,
geographic or political area,
the more inequality
pressure you put on it,
the more men slip past that
threshold and into criminality.
And you know,
there's been pretty good studies
done of drug gang in Chicago.
That was the best one is
sociologist actually went
and hung out with a drug gang
for,
he got into it.
I guess the drug gang leader was,
no,
I wouldn't say necessarily narcissistic,
but that might be a reasonable
way of thinking about it.
And he was kind of happy with the idea
of maybe being a subject of a book and,
and so this guy was able
to associate with them,
got to know them quite well.
And then the housing project in which
the gang was housed was slated for
demolition and the gang broke up and he
got the books because they kept books.
And what he found was the
average street drug dealer,
first of all was employed in another
job as well and was making far less than
minimum wage now.
But the guy is,
you know,
further up the chain of course
followed the Prieto distribution.
And so there was a tiny minority of them
who were raking in a tremendous amount
of loot.
And the guys at the bottom,
we're just waiting around for the
possibility that they could rise up the
hierarchy and you know,
it's pretty violent game.
So the chances that someone is going to be
taken out is pretty high and then a little
slot opens up for some opportunistic
second rater and perhaps he
can move up the hierarchy.